[Music]
I've got plenty to be thankful
for my needs are small I buy them all at
the 5 and 10 cent store oh I've got PL
to be thankful
[Music]
for I used to love this
town until what happened that
night tomorrow's Thanksgiving and I'm
tired of pretending like everything is
normal and it's not I want things to go
back to normal
too show some enthusiasm Thanksgiving is
an institution
here
[Applause]
no no no
no someone's out for revenge and they're
turning it into a sick holiday
game this is weird we're all tagged and
our names are at the table but why
[Music]
us
the longer this goes the more Twisted it
gets every weapon he's using is straight
off a Thanksgiving table I don't want to
spend my life looking over my shoulder
we need to stop
[Applause]
him
[Music]
it is going to be a very Happy
Thanksgiving let's
see show starts in 1
minute to
theob to
theob all go to the lobby to get
[Music]
ourselves someone is killing my
children someone help them on uprooting
life in Fairwood as we know and making
us forget who we are and where we've
come
from
right now right
now get
off and now on with the
show there's a young
man I talk to him I wish I have SP
[Music]
you that's really weird
Lisa Taffy says it's a waste of time to
try and fix a way it's better just
accept a guys fls oh that's so
[Music]
cute
I can't do that not until we bury the
body there is no tur back
now I can't be
saved and in the next life they remember
me remember
me you
remember
really hope this goth phase in
soon it needs a little work but I don't
think it's going to last long at this
price there's a
pool where want to
pool is this everything we'll grow into
it yall
ready
Marco
H Marco
H
Marco I I hear you
you need to say something
back Ronin
[Music]
Marco
Marco I can hear you
why aren't you saying
anything Ronin you're
dead
Marco
[Music]
I
I have a job for you piece of cake
really give your
head it's a security
gig
hello welcome to Freddy's have you met
them
yet met who
foxy Bonnie Chica and
[Music]
Freddy back in
the80s some kids went missing what is
this it's why the place shut
down the police searched Freddy's hey
they never found the
kid on the
heck
ghost
children possessing giant
robots tell me how to stop
them you don't it's too
late he's
[Music]
coming
there's something wrong with the
school something doesn't feel
[Music]
right Sophie what
happened I think there's something
here that's not meant to
be
what did you
[Applause]
see I saw
none what she
doing she's standing
[Music]
this thing has come back for
me this demon was once an
angel rejected by
God stripped of
power it wants that power
back it's okay to be scared
I'm scared
too you send that thing back to
[Music]
hell
how does it feel being back good I had
such good memories here maybe my happy
place can be our happy place we left you
all alone down
herein I'm playing a new game with chy
the scavenger hunt list that's fun chy
says you're not allowed to play with us
oh because you left him I need something
happy something happy oh I thought bugs
freaked you out if I can finish my list
try will take me on a trip to the place
he's
[Music]
from something that hurts
Alice you've been spending time with a
new
[Music]
friend here has you to do something that
hurt you that was part of the game does
that seem like a game a good friend
would want to play maybe we shouldn't
play together anymore johy maybe we
shouldn't be friends no no no
no Alice Alice Alice Alice Alice
Alice she's lost but we're going to find
her
every culture has entities that tether
to the young we call them imaginary
friends you are always playing with your
imaginary friend when the connection was
severed The Entity becomes
enraged he says he's right behind
you it was just my
imagin can I hang out with your
imaginary friend he's not
imaginary and he's not your
[Applause]
friend who is it it's nothing oh dude
it's Pete oh my gosh brother thought it
was pretty
funny here in Salem they didn't teach us
all our
history some stories got lost along the
way maybe if they had taught us
everything that happened my brother
would have left that knife where he
found it I will play I won't
quit you know what I think we should do
right now go to the party come on let's
go don't
let if you play with me then I'll let
you go to your party and I won't call on
okay Joe what game do you want to
play I'm not playing dog dog Goose just
humor him you'll all say I will play I
won't quit tell me demon am I
it
morgus what is you do let's
play Marcus are you ready to play hide
and seek Marcus why you have that knife
five why are you doing this
four
three
2 Go what is going on it's not him it's
the
knife found
you hey buddy you're just messing with
us right how about some hman it only
ends when we
wins what if we win only one way to find
out I will
play I won't quit happing help I will
play Moran I won't
quit I will play I won't quit
no let's play a new
game
Angel Falls I give you
Christmas the lights are so pretty this
is
[Music]
perfect what did you
eat
help please help
me please
go
Mar
Waters last Christmas still haunts
me time to let that go no one
cares everyone would be better off if I
was never
born did you see that did the power go
up oh my
God I stood under the Aurora and said
everyone would be better off if I never
existed well wish granted
Angel strikes every couple of weeks how
can that be do I know you it's Winnie
you know that okay this her hi hi I'm
Henry Waters you're safe now he's not
going to get
you no one in this town knows me who are
you dad you weren't around to stop him
so he just kept going he likes
killing on here now let's have some
fun hey you hey Merry
Christmas
we got to stop him and get my life
back you be safe
[Music]
now
good
[Music]
and
child
[Music]
Santa
the cancer is still spreading I'm afraid
there's nothing else we can do there is
one person who might be able to help our
program is a two-prong treatment outside
Mexico City the results of been stunning
she saved my
[Music]
life you're in very good hands with
us after that what happens then your
whole life happens then John
Kramer according to these
scans the tumor was never
removed how much gun do I have months at
best I still have a lot of work that
needs to be done
hello everyone it's time to play a
game you all pretended to cure me but
what I have planned for each of you is
very real
Came Upon
Me No
Light
No the only thing I have not provided is
your anesthetic but trust
me you will want to remain
alert
sound all I need is the
of all the men to cheat you pick John
Kramer please don't
hesitate place a big enough piece of
your cerebral tissue into the glass
enzyme tank this will save your life
so this is not retribution it's a real
Awakening all I need is the that
live or die the choice is
yours
[Music]
come
h
a
don't be
scared we've met
before are you looking for Reagan are
you looking for rean he RS in
[Music]
hell what do you think evil
is I'll tell you what I think it is
we're born in this world with Hope and
Dreams and a desire to be happy
Dad something's going on with my
daughter no no it's happening to my
daughter too the devil has one wish
Wherever those girls went they brought
something back with
them to make us lose faith I believe you
can help get our daughters back to kill
it in us and the devil never gives
up she knows who I
am where's the other
girl she is waiting
him what are you're doing here is
dangerous people have died on both sides
of
possession come on baby come back to us
okay if you don't make it I don't make
it mama what is it I can't you I'm right
here I don't want to go to
hell God play that drink on
you they're two heartbeats is it working
they're beating in
syn they
strong what did you
do one girl lives one girl dies you get
choose
[Music]
[Applause]
hey thanks for coming come on let's get
her in she's lost a lot of
blood no idea and had multiple
aerations he's coming
I'm with Social Services I'm not going
to hurt you do you know who did this to
you anything on that girl last night let
us do our
jobs girls have been disappearing around
for
years this place never
disappoints What If there really is
someone out there killing lots of
them
but are you feel that
me women get reported missing all the
timey and most of them turn out to be
nothing be
ready these type of situations lost
calls stay the [__] out of my
job there were some [__] asking just a
lot of
questions
V so beautiful you hear the music you
just couldn't leave it alone could you I
just need a little more time
[Music]
darling this is your
salvation
[Music]
where do you think we should come
wherever just enjoy every second of
getting the heck out of
[Applause]
L the hell is
[Music]
that first place I learned about death
was a pet
cemetery
the secret
[Music]
place generation to
Generation Dead things buried in that
land but come
back there's something
[Applause]
else can you hear them
voices I think something's wrong with
Dey he needs time to adjust
the people built the pet
cemetery to protect them from
Evil that's not
Timmy something's talking through
him B what have you
done we have to find
[Music]
Tim stop this I held him the day he came
into this world and I'm going to hold
him the day he goes
out believe me when I
say sometimes dead is
better
foree
spee
fore
for
[Music]
Fore
spee spee
spee
spe
fire now it's time get we
together
in Alice engaging with trolls is like
the worst possible use of your
[Music]
energy since you joined BuzzFeed your
art got super
lame a you dying a
fire don't judge me sometimes you got to
troll the trolls why is you all up in my
[Music]
mes
do you know how to find out who this
handle belongs to you really think a
weird account is haunting your
apartment dear David who was only 10 and
his mother went insane Linda it's Dr
Landers this is not my son he is your
son and you put him in a
coma oh my God Dr
Landers
[Music]
what what the hell is
that oh my
God see my son David haven't you what
does he want ask him
yourself it's
Halloween you know what that means
me old Sawtooth J Jack is going to rise
from the corn fields it's got to be
stopped kill or be killed you've all
heard the stories we failed at our
duties and that black dust destroyed our
crops Our Lives it must
die so we can live your sacred duty is
to take down saw tooth Jack before that
church bell rings at midnight you really
think that's real I saw it
it's
real you saw
it did you kill
it then let's go kill
[Music]
it you should do it you know I'm not
allowed just cuz your brother want to
run last
you I got an
idea if that thing isn't dead by
midnight this whole t it's going
straight to
hell I want to go home I want to go home
you think you're special why are you
doing
this if you're born in this town you're
cursed I'm ending
this
tonight it ain't
[Music]
over
I'd like to report a crime that hasn't
happened yet have you seen the movie
Back to the Future basically I'm living
that movie right now which is how I know
there's going to be a murder
tonight hate time travel movies it never
make any
sense happy Halloween how about we all
stay in and hand out Halloween candy
know Mom you know how hard this time of
year is for us your friends were
murdered 35 years ago it's not 1987
anymore stay safe honey I love you
[Music]
what the
[__] excuse me what year is it 1987 oh
my God I know the 80s are almost over
and I haven't even tried Coke yet I know
I don't
know oh my God Mom [__] off and die
Jesus
momita
Mita time for my birthday
[__] this is a creepy ass cabin in the
middle of [__] nowhere what's the big
deal there is a murderer on the loose
and you drove us into the woods oh my
God I forgot to bring
[Music]
vodka you have 7 and 1 half hours until
you're stuck here
forever I need to stop all this horror
before it
happens the machines kill us all no they
more just rip apart the fabric of our
society via Dance videos on Tik Tok they
dance against
us come on out water's warm just so you
know I don't do [__] you pee out of
that
thing just think maybe if she did do
[__] she'd still be alive yeah let's
not make that the
[Music]
lesson 8s weed sucks this is just dirt
look at all these Twigs I could give you
a gummy this big that has 100 times more
weed than
[Music]
[Applause]
this
hello Joe
where let's discuss your new job what
job I got a wife she's pregnant please
let me
go at Mard your work consists of pushing
the
mill failure to meet your daily quota
will result in a
punishment the employee with the fewest
points will be
terminated
[Applause]
when do I go
home you are well on your
[Applause]
way oh
[__] you still don't believe the rules
apply to
you perhaps you would respond to other
incentives you took everything for
me what is this you're still asking
questions walk through the door prepare
your mind for a transformative
experience by
malard you're a crucial part of our team
for
[Music]
life